Willkommen an der Militärakademie
in Wiener Neustadt.
Mein Name ist Oberst Markus Reisner.
Ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs- und
Entwicklungsabteilung der Theresianischen Militärakademie.
Und heute wollen wir uns in einem neuen
Video damit befassen,
welche Fähigkeiten und Taktiken im
Hintergrund eine ganz wesentliche
Rolle in diesem Konflikt spielen.
Fähigkeiten und Taktiken, die uns auf den
ersten Blick gar nicht auffallen, die aber
ganz wesentlich zum Erfolg - vor allem der
ukrainischen Seite - bis
jetzt beigetragen haben.
Dazu müssen wir ganz kurz den Konflikt
seit dem 24. Februar betrachten.
Am Beginn, in den ersten zwei Wochen, war es so,
dass die russische Seite relativ rasch
Geländegewinne durchführen konnte.
Es gab einen Angriff an vier Fronten: im
Norden, im Nordosten, Osten und im Süden
und der Vormarsch war davon geprägt, dass
die russischen Truppen rasch
vorangeschritten sind.
In der dritten Woche begannen dann die
ersten Herausforderungen, die
sich weiter fortgesetzt haben.
Das waren die Angriffe
auf die Logistik-Konvois.
Das waren die Angriffe der ukrainischen
Spezialkräfte ganz gezielt auf Gefechtsstände.
Es war aber vor allem auch der Einsatz der
Artillerie, der dazu beigetragen hat, dass
am Ende der sechsten Woche die russische
Seite entschieden hat, ein Schwergewicht
im Donbass zu bilden, die Truppen im
Norden abzuziehen und sich
hier neu zu konzentrieren.
Und wenn wir die letzten Wochen
betrachten, so sieht man auch, dass die
Kämpfe sich vor allem
im Donbass abspielen.
Die ukrainische Seite versucht dem
entgegenzuwirken durch Angriffe an den
anderen Frontlinien, und die Russen
versuchen hier entsprechend
entgegenzuhalten.
Jetzt kann man sich die Frage stellen, in
diesen letzten knapp zwölf Wochen, was hat
gut funktioniert und warum
hat es so gut funktioniert?
Wir wissen, drei wesentliche
Dinge waren der Fall.
Das erste war die Taktik der Ukraine. Der
Einsatz gegen die Logistiklinien, gegen
die Logistikkonvois, der Einsatz der
gezielten Artillerieschläge, aber auch
der Einsatz der Spezialkräfte und
natürlich die hohe Moral
der ukrainischen Soldaten.
Das zweite Wesentliche sind natürlich die
massiven Waffenlieferungen, vor allem jene
Waffensysteme, die am Beginn geholfen
haben, diesen Abnützungeffekt auf
der russischen Seite durchzuführen.
Und das dritte Element, das auch ganz
wesentlich ist, ist natürlich die Übermittlung
von Aufklärungsdaten der USA und NATO,
die die ukrainische Seite befähigt
hat, diese Einsätze durchzuführen.
Schauen wir uns nun im Speziellen die
Artillerie an. Denn der Einsatz der
ukrainischen Artillerie ist sehr
bemerkenswert und erscheint für uns sehr
wichtig, wenn wir diesen
Konflikt betrachten.
Hier hab ich kurz skizziert den
traditionellen, sehr vereinfacht
dargestellten Einsatz von Artillerie.
Wir haben einen sogenannten Forward
Observer, der abgesessen oder mit
einer Drohne ein Ziel aufklären kann.
Diese Daten übermittelt er dann über eine C2
Struktur, also "Command and
Control" an ein Führungselement,
das diese Feueranforderung dann an ein
Wirksystem, in diesem Fall eine
BM-27-Batterie weitergibt.
Diese BM-27-Batterie
befindet sich in einem definierten
Stellungsraum, einer "Position Area Artillery".
Die Kommunikation funktioniert durch ein
"Battle Management System" oder ein
Führungsinformationssystem.
Wenn ein Ziel erkannt wird, dann wird das
Ziel aufgeklärt und diese
Zieldaten weitergegeben.
Und in letzter Konsequenz kommt es zum
Einsatz von einem Wirkmittel
auf das Ziel selbst.
Im Laufe der letzten Jahrzehnte konnte
diese Zeit, die man dazu gebraucht hat,
immer wieder optimiert werden, von wenigen
Minuten, die man dazu gebraucht hat.
Beziehungsweise wurde sie auch
immer wieder in die Länge gezogen
aufgrund der Vorgaben, zum Beispiel, des
humanitären Völkerrechts - also die Frage:
Besteht die Gefahr eines
Kollateralschadens?
Das zu prüfen war, ob diese
Anforderung wirklich legitim war.
Der Punkt war, dass bei einem derartigen
traditionellen Einsatz immer das Problem
bestand, dass, wenn der Gegner bewirkt
worden ist durch ein Wirksystem,
er natürlich versucht hat dem
entgegenzuwirken, indem er durch eigene
Artilleriesysteme
ein Gegenfeuer durchgeführt hat.
Das heißt, in diesem Fall
hat also quasi die russische Seite mit
einer Batterie BM-21 die ukrainische Seite
bewirkt und hier schwere
Ausfälle verursacht.
Zusätzlich kommt hinzu,
dass die Kommunikation
immer wieder der Herausforderung durch
Störer unterliegt, das heißt die
Kommunikation sehr eingeschränkt
durchgeführt wird bzw. es Herausforderungen
gibt, die man nicht lösen kann, und damit
auch die Zeit für die Feueranforderung
sich in die Länge zieht.
Wenn wir uns nun die Erfahrungen der
ukrainischen Seite anschauen aus dem
Konflikt mit Beginn 2014 und den letzten
Jahren, so erkennt man anhand dieses
Beispiels, dass die Masse der Ausfälle der
ukrainischen Seite,
was die Kampffahrzeuge betroffen hat, vor allem
durch gegnerische Artilleriesysteme erfolgt ist.
Sie sehen das hier an diesen Balken,
wo Sie sehen, dass gepanzerte Fahrzeuge zu
45% ausgefallen sind aufgrund von
Artillerietreffern, Artilleriesysteme sogar aufgrund von 65%.
Ein klarer Indikator für erfolgreiches
Gegenfeuer der russischen Seite
oder auch allgemeine Fahrzeuge zu 57%.
Das heißt, die ukrainische Seite musste
etwas ändern, um bei einem neuen
Konflikt hier erfolgreicher zu sein.
Was war das?
Sie haben die Art und Weise des
Artillerieeinsatzes geändert.
Das System blieb grundsätzlich gleich.
Es gibt nach wie vor den Beobachter,
der ein Ziel erkennen kann.
Es ist aber so, dass der Feuerstellungsraum der
Artillerie in einer viel
aufgelockerteren Form passiert.
Im sogenannten Stellungsraumverfahren.
Das heißt, die Geschütze oder Wirkmittel
sind auf einen größeren Raum verteilt.
Die Kommunikation erfolgt
durch zwei Dinge:
Einerseits durch eine sehr gezielt von der
ukrainischen Seite entwickelte
Software namens GIS ARTA.
Aber auch in Kommunikation mit einem
Verbindungsmittel, das wir so nicht am
Radar haben, das aber eine sehr wichtige Rolle
spielt, nämlich mit dem System
Starlink von Elon Musk.
Wie läuft jetzt ein derartiger Einsatz ab?
Auch hier ist es so, dass wenn ein Ziel
erkannt wird,
diese Daten, also die Koordinaten,
aufgenommen werden von den
Beobachtern und weitergegeben werden.
Hier ist es aber wichtig zu verstehen,
dass die Weitergabe der Daten
so erfolgt, dass viele in sehr kurzer Zeit
die Möglichkeit haben,
ihre Fähigkeiten zur Anwendung zu bringen,
das heißt ihre Waffensysteme einzusetzen.
Das heißt, durch diese App, im Wesentlichen,
ist es möglich, diese Koordination
durchzuführen, in einer Form, dass die
Zeit für die Feueranforderung wesentlich
verringert wird, auf wenige Minuten.
Und dann alle jene Systeme, die in der
Nähe sind oder die effektive Reichweite haben
sofort wirksam werden können.
Zusätzlich noch in Kombination mit dem
Umstand, dass die Munition, die dafür
eingesetzt wird, wie hier in diesem
Fall, eine endphasengesteuerte Munition ist.
Der große Vorteil ist: Wenn jetzt die
russische Seite versucht, mit Gegenfeuer
zu antworten,
dann hat sie das Problem, dass aufgrund
des dezentralen Einsatzes der Batterie
oder der Wirkmittel, sie vor der
Herausforderung steht,
ihr maximales Feuer auf sehr wenige
Möglichkeiten konzentrieren zu müssen.
Das heißt, sie kann die Batterie
als Gesamtes nicht vernichten.
Das Problem besteht auch, dass durch diese
Satellitenkommunikation der Einsatz von
Störern sehr schwierig wird, die
normalerweise den Funkverkehr stören,
sondern der russische Angriff muss also
auf diese Satellitenkommunikation
abzielen.
Sehen wir uns nun die Kernelemente des
Einsatzes der ukrainischen Artillerie noch
einmal im Detail an. Dazu habe ich im
öffentlichen Netz einige Recherchen
durchgeführt und die Kernaussagen
möchte ich Ihnen nun zeigen.
Beginnen wir mit dieser App:
GIS-ARTA, von ukrainischen Software-
Ingenieuren entwickelt, in sehr
kurzer Zeit und sehr effektiv.
Der große Vorteil ist die schnelle
Unterstützung, eine sehr einfache
Benutzeroberfläche, wie in diesen Bildern
erkennbar, wo die Koordinaten eingegeben
werden und rasch den Fähigkeitsträgern,
also den Artilleriesystemen,
zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Das zweite Wesentliche ist
Starlink, das System von Elon Musk.
Hier wissen wir, dass
die Benutzeroberfläche
ebenfalls sehr einfach ist.
Das heißt, wir haben
eine gewisse Bandbreite.
Wir haben die Möglichkeit der
Kommunikation über viele Satelliten, über
1.760 Satelliten, die sich hier
bereits in der Erdumlaufbahn befinden.
Und wir haben auch Bandbreiten, die große
Datenmengen zu übertragen zulassen.
Wir wissen auch, dass am Beginn die
russische Seite sehr wohl
versucht hat, dies zu stören.
Dabei gab es sogar einen Side-Effekt in
den europäischen Ländern, wo zum Beispiel
sehr viele Windkraftanlagen
betroffen waren.
Elon Musk gibt hier in diesem Tweet
bekannt, dass es nicht gelungen ist, der
russischen Seite, das System zu stören.
Und diese Versuche dauern auch an.
Wir sehen das hier in einem weiteren
kurzen Twitter-Eintrag von Elon Musk
vor wenigen Tagen, wo er darauf hinweist,
dass die russische Seite nach wie vor
versucht, die Kommunikation zu stören.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Weil diese Kommunikation ganz
wesentlich dazu beiträgt, dass die
ukrainische Seite vor allem ihre
Artilleriesysteme einsetzen kann.
Dieses dezentrale Internet spielt also
eine wesentliche Rolle im Konflikt.
Das dritte wichtige Element ist,
wie bereits erwähnt, die Munition.
Hier ist ganz interessant, dass die
ukrainische Seite
ein russisches System nachgebaut hat.
Die russische Seite hat sogenannte endphasen-
gesteuerte Artilleriegranaten
vom Typ Krasnopol.
Die ukrainische Seite hat diese nachgebaut
und hat ihr eigenes System
entwickelt namens Kvitnyk.
Das ist auch der Hintergrund, warum wir
oft in den Videos sehr gezielte
Artillerie-Einschläge sehen.
Der erste Treffer ist oft bereits
der, der das Fahrzeug zerstört.
Das heißt "Precise Targeting",
dezentrale Kommunikation,
aber auch der Umstand, hier rasch wirksam
werden zu können, ist ganz wesentlich für
die Einsatzführung der ukrainischen Artillerie.
Sehen wir uns nun ein paar
ausgewählte Beispiele an.
Ein Beispiel vom Beginn des Konflikts, das war
dieser rasche Vorstoß aus dem Raum Sumi
der russischen Kräfte entlang einer
zentral geführten Linie in Richtung Kiew.
Hier gibt es ein sehr bekanntes Video, wo
man erkennen kann, dass der russische
Konvoi sehr gezielt durch Artillerie
angegriffen wird und viele
Fahrzeuge zerstört werden.
Ein gutes Beispiel für den sehr
frühen Einsatz von GIS ARTA.
Ein zweites Beispiel ist Gegenfeuer.
Auch hier ein Beispiel aus dem Süden des
Landes. Es gibt immer wieder Artillerie-
Duelle zwischen Mikolajew und
Cherson, von beiden Seiten.
Hier gibt es auch ein Video,
das sehr interessant ist.
Es zeigt nämlich eine gezogene
russische Artilleriebatterie
nach dem Gegenfeuer durch die ukrainische
Seite mit sehr verheerender Wirkung.
Auch hier kann man gut erkennen,
dass das Artilleriefeuer der Russen
sofort von ukrainischer Seite lokalisiert
worden ist und es eine effektives
Gegenfeuer gegeben hat.
Der dritte nicht zu unterschätzende
Fall ist auch hier ein Beispiel, um zu
zeigen, dass gerade auch der Angriff der
ukrainischen Artillerie auf die Führungs-
kommunikation und Führungsstruktur
ganz wesentlich war.
Wir wissen, dass bis heute circa 13
russische Generäle und man nimmt
an über 20 Oberste gefallen sind.
Warum ist das der Fall?
Weil die ukrainische Seite sehr gezielt
versucht hat, die
Gefechtsstände anzugreifen.
Hier ein Beispiel aus dem Raum Isjum.
Isjum ist jener Raum, wo die russische
Seite versucht, bei der Schlacht im
Donbass, die sogenannte nördliche
Zangenbewegung zu entwickeln.
Hier gab es am 30. April
einen Angriff auf Zabavne, wo man
annimmt, dass ein russischer General,
nämlich jener General, der verantwortlich
für die elektronische Kampfführung ist,
getötet worden ist durch den gezielten
Einsatz der ukrainischen Artillerie.
Schlüsselmomente in der Schlacht sind
natürlich wesentliche
Treiber des Konflikts.
Auch hier ist ein Beispiel, das in den
letzten Tagen sehr intensiv kommuniziert
worden ist, wieder
heranzuziehen, um zu zeigen, dass der
gezielte ukrainische Einsatz der Artillerie
sehr effektiv sein kann.
Die Situation war die, dass in der Nähe
von Bilhorivka, in der Nähe von Sjewjerodonezk,
die russische Seite versucht hat, durch
mehrere Brückenschläge die ukrainische
Seite in der Tiefe zu umfassen.
Das hat am Beginn auch funktioniert.
Man ist über den Siwerskyj Donez, diesen markanten Fluss,
hinübergekommen und hat Kräfte
bereitgestellt am Ostufer.
Diese Kräfte wurden aber zurückgedrängt.
Daraufhin hat die russische Seite
versucht, an anderer Stelle einen neuen
Brückenschlag durchzuführen. Auch dieser
war nicht erfolgreich.
Woraufhin die russische Seite zum dritten
Mal versucht hat, eine Brücke zu legen
und hier massiv Kräfte hinüber zu führen.
Die ukrainische Seite hat diese Zeit
aber genützt und hat bis zum 10. Mai
nicht nur eigene Kräfte
zusammengeführt, sondern auch
Artilleriesysteme bereitgestellt.
Und als die Russen versucht haben, massiv
über diese zwei Pontonbrücken den Fluss zu
überqueren, kam es zu einem
vernichtenden Abwehrfeuer.
Und man nimmt an, dass vermutlich zwei
Bataillonstaktische Gruppen hier
zerschlagen, wenn nicht gar
vernichtet worden sind.
Auch hier wieder ein Beispiel der guten
Koordination der ukrainischen Artillerie
zur Erreichung eines
gezielten Abwehrerfolges.
Am Ende des Videos möchte ich
Ihnen dieses Bild zeigen:
Es zeigt eine russische "Msta"-Batterie,
schwere Artilleriegeschütze vom Kaliber
152 Millimeter, die sich hier in
einem Windschutzgürtel  untergezogen haben.
Das ist ein klarer Indikator dafür, dass
man versucht, möglichst unerkannt
das Feuer weiter an den Feind zu bringen.
Wir haben aber auch hier noch immer diesen
traditionellen Feuerstellungsraum, wo die
Geschütze relativ eng
nebeneinander stehen.
Interessant ist, dass die ukrainische
Seite einen Mix zwischen alter Taktik
und neuer Taktik angewandt hat.
Das heißt, wir haben innovative
Taktiken und Gefechtstechniken und wir
haben herkömmliche Taktiken.
Und beides in Kombination, wie in diesem Zitat
auch dargestellt, hat offensichtlich dazu
geführt, dass die ukrainische Seite in den
letzten zwölf Wochen des Konflikts, vor
allem was den Einsatz der Artillerie
betroffen hat, sehr erfolgreich
diese Maßnahmen durchgeführt hat.
Damit bin ich am Ende und ich sage
herzlichen Dank fürs Zuhören.